hello everyone i'm dom meijang from
microsoft research asia very glad to
have this opportunity today to share
with you our research on cloud
intelligence infusing ai into cloud
computing systems
i'll first talk about the motivation of
our work
then i will introduce the concept of
cloud intelligence and its research
landscape followed by two example
projects i'll share our learnings and
future research opportunities at the end
when talking about the motivation of our
work let's take a moment to look at what
was happening in the software industry
in the past 10 to 15 years
one significant paradigm shift was the
migration to cloud computing
more and more businesses in different
industries have realized the benefits to
migrate to the cloud in the era of
digital transformation
businesses need to collect huge amounts
of data store the data process the data
get insights from the data and use the
insights to take actions to improve
their existing businesses as well as
create new business opportunities
they need to do all of these at scale
with low cost and high agility they
cannot afford to use the traditional i.t
approach to achieve this especially for
small and medium businesses
therefore cloud computing will be a
natural choice for them
doctor's prediction
also supports the migration to cloud
computing the table on the left shows
the percentage of cloud shift in the
next few years after 2018 for different
types of software the table on the right
shows the predicted market value for
different types of cloud services from
2019 to 22.
copy 19 accelerated the migration to the
cloud
the implication of this is profound it
means that cloud computing platform is
becoming part of the basic
infrastructure of our society
the non-functional properties of cloud
computing systems would become immensely
important
including availability reliability
performance security etc
as researchers in the industry research
lab we have experienced the impact of
the trend of cloud computing on one hand
azir is one of microsoft's big bats it
has massive skill with more than 60
regions in the world and millions of
physical machines
on the other hand cloud computing and
the digital transformation it enabled
got us to think about digital
transformation and software industry
on the surface the question might seem
odd since software is naturally digital
but deep down the question is really
about how we develop software operates
off our system and engage with customers
we realize that software analytics the
interdisciplinary research direction we
proposed in 2009 that utilizes the
data-driven approach to address various
challenges in the software domain is the
digital transformation of the software
industry itself
given the paradigm shift to cloud
computing we focus on software analytics
research on cloud computing we call this
new topic cloud intelligence
cloud intelligence is to utilize
ai and ml technologies to design build
and operate complex cloud services at
scale
centered around three key elements in
cloud computing service customer and
engineering cloud intelligence has three
major topics ai for system ai for devops
and ai for customer
the north star of cloud intelligence is
for cloud services to have built-in
intelligence meaning they should monitor
themselves analyze and assess the status
and they should be capable of
self-adjusting and adapting
to new conditions
of course there will be developers and
operators in the loop when needed
with such intelligence when dealing with
service issues the services will be
proactive instead of reactive in order
to minimize customer impact
working with our colleagues at microsoft
we have been promoting the research and
practice of cloud intelligence both
inside and outside microsoft we
initiated the cult intelligence workshop
series in research communities with
steering committee members from both
academia and industry the first workshop
was at triple ai 2020 and the second
workshop was at ixe this year
with this effort we hope to create a
forum for researchers and practitioners
from ai software engineering and system
communities to work together on this
exciting interdisciplinary research
topic
in recent years aiops has become a very
popular word it was first coined by
gartner in 2017 to refer to the
application of machine learning and data
science to i.t operation problems
compared to cloud intelligence garner's
ai ops concept focuses only on devops
whereas cloud intelligence has a much
broader scope including ai for system
and ai for customer we would like to
extend the scope of ai ops to make it
exchangeable with cloud intelligence
now let's look at the scenarios of cloud
intelligence for services the scenarios
are around service health specifically
how to measure surface health that spans
multiple aspects including availability
reliability performance security etc
using various metrics of components and
resources how to detect anomalous
behaviors that may lead to service
health problems furthermore instead of
passive response can we predict service
problems before they occur so that we
can take proactive actions and what
actions can we recommend
for engineering all the scenarios are
familiar but many of them may present
new challenges in the context of cloud
computing
for example incident triage is more
complex than bug triage because instance
or implant service interruptions or
service outages
since online service systems are highly
complex one incident may lead to another
and many others meaning although these
incidents are reported by different
monitors they are all related and share
the same root cause
in this case the traditional bug triage
techniques may not be sufficient to
triage incidents
for customers let's look at intelligent
customer support to cut down costs and
improve efficiency how can we enable
self-service for customers how can we
provide actionable suggestions to
customers
when customer does talk to a service
support personnel how can we help make
the communication easier and efficient
the scenarios of cloud
intelligence are quite broad when we
find more when we go deep into the space
when we explore the scenarios of cloud
intelligence we find that four major
problem categories can be extracted out
across different scenarios namely
detection diagnosis prediction and
optimization
each problem has its own challenges
let's take detection as an example
to ensure service health at runtime it
is important to continuously monitor
various metrics and detect anomalies in
a timely manner
in the development process for example
we are doing continuous integration and
continuous deployment we should have
mechanisms to catch the defective bills
in order to prevent them from being
deployed to more production sites
both scenarios require timely detection
furthermore in both cases there are
common challenges for conducting
effective detection for example time
series data and log data are the most
common data forms and they are often
multi-dimensional the data may be noisy
and there may be different requirements
on the detection etc
on the right hand side i'm listing some
of our work in the past few years trying
to tackle some of the challenges in
cloud intelligence
next i'll use two example projects to
show what we have done
the first project is this failure
prediction
availability is a critical issue for
cloud computing platforms and hardware
issues are one of the top reasons that
cause vm to go down and reboot
as our partners in azure found these
problems are the most severe one among
hardware issues
a typical cloud system like azure uses
hundreds of millions of disks making
disk related problems a top priority to
address
to reduce vm downtime it is not enough
to replace disks after they fail we must
take actions before digs fail which
requires us to do prediction
in general this failure prediction can
be formulated into a binary
classification problem
given a time series collection of disk
attributes predict whether a disk will
fail or not after a certain period of
time
are three key challenges in solving this
problem
what features to use what model to use
and how to address the huge data
imbalance problem
a lot of research has been done
on this problem in the past 10 years
here are some representative ones based
on their underlying machine learning
models
these works fall into two categories
one uses the traditional machine
learning models such as svm decision
tree and random forest
the other uses deep learning based
approaches such as rnn and lstm
i'd like to share some of our
observations when working on big failure
prediction
the first observation is that in general
disks exhibit errors before they
completely fail
based on our statistics on average disk
errors occurred about 16 days earlier
than complete these failures
these errors such as latency errors
timeout and sector errors are often
reflected by the system level signals
such as os events recording symptoms
such as file open errors vm not
responding to communication requests etc
this observation helps us address the
problem of what feature to use
most of the existing approaches only use
the smart data that monitor the internal
attributes of individual disks
in our work in addition to smart data we
also use system level signals such as os
events as shown in the table
besides driver related attributes such
as flush count and controller reset are
another useful source
the second observation is that each
individual disk is not independent
instead it has neighbors because a set
of disks can be in the same storage
array or they can be associated with the
same server
managing data access or they can be
associated with the same computing node
etc
this implies that
the health status of a disk may be
related to the health status of its
neighbors
based on this observation we designed a
neighborhood aware component as shown
here for each disk ai we represent its
status using a vector ri called neighbor
encoded vector ri encodes the status of
ai and all its neighbors
it is used as input to the next
component of enzyme
our third observation is that
if a disk fails at time t
then there exists a leading time l that
the disk samples collected between t
minus l and t
carry information indicating the
upcoming failure
so we mark these samples failure samples
which effectively addresses the huge
challenge of imbalanced data which can
be as low as three to ten thousand
we call this data enhancement method tps
which stands for
temporal progressive sampling
the leading time l is treated as a
hyperparameter in the model
here's an overview of our proposed
neighborhood temporal attention model
intam
it is an end-to-end deep learning based
approach it has three components the
neighborhood award component we just
introduced the temporal component that
also leverages the attention mechanism
to better capture the temporal
information and the decision component
that determines the failure probability
of a disk
we evaluated end time against 10
state-of-the-art baselines on two
industry data sets and one public
dataset
intent achieve the best performance in
all evaluations
this is the result on the industry
datasets
this is the result on the public dataset
this result shows the effectiveness of
tps
now let me talk about the second project
intelligent virtual machine
pre-provisioning
vm provisioning is a system management
process that creates a new vm on a
physical host server and allocates
computing resources to support the vm
the computing resources typically
include cpu and memory and it may also
involve storage and network bandwidth
provisioning is the most common and
essential operation in azure its
performance meaning how fast it is
directly impacts users experiences
therefore the provisioning performance
is one of the top metrics in azure
to accelerate vm provisioning a common
practice is to get a pool of resources
and pre-provision some vms
this way when a vm creation request
comes in
if there's a match in the
pre-provisioned vm pool then this vm can
be directly related to complete the rest
of the provisioning process otherwise
the new vm has to be provisioned from
scratch resulting in longer provisioning
time as shown in this pps process the
pre-provisioning algorithm plays a
critical role because it decides how
many vms should be pre-provisioned for
each vm type
now let's look closely at the vm
pre-provision problem there are two
knowns and two unknowns the size of the
research pool is known it poses a
constraint on pre-provisioning the
historical demands for each vm type are
known
one unknown is the future demand for
each vm type the other is how to fit the
future demands into the resource pool
formerly given end time series as input
each representing the demand of a vm
type from t0 to t and minus 1 the output
of the output is the number of vms to be
provisioned
at time t for each vm type
we formulate the problem as a prediction
and optimization problem with the
objective function to maximize the
pre-provisioning heat rate and minimize
the over prevision rate
here the hit rate means the percentage
of the incoming vm provisioning requests
fulfilled by the pre-provisioned vms
obviously we want to maximize this
metric
over provision rate means the percentage
of pre-provisioned vms that are not used
it is important to minimize the over
provision rate to achieve high
efficiency on resource utilization
when we solve the problem we should take
the set of constraints on cpu memory
storage and network bandwidth into
consideration
the vm pre-provisioning problem is quite
challenging first there are huge numbers
of vms and their demand patterns are
very different this makes the demand
prediction extremely difficult
second prediction introduces uncertainty
which impacts the final result through
optimization how can we take this factor
into consideration to achieve better
result
last but not least the number of vms for
each vm type is discrete and all the
constraints are discrete making this
optimization problem mp hard
we propose a uncertainty aware framework
for prediction and optimization to solve
this problem
there are three components in this
framework in the prediction component we
use ensembl learning to address the
challenge of predicting demands for huge
number of vm types with very different
demand patterns
please note that since this is a
framework other predictive methods can
be used here
the prediction component outputs the
predicted vm demand for each vm type and
the corresponding prediction uncertainty
this is different from the existing
two-state approaches that only output
the predicted demand to the opt-in
optimization component
in the optimization component we use a
two mode heuristic search approach to do
the optimization here two mode means
that we try to balance greediness and
the randomness in order to avoid local
minimum during optimization
here i want to point out that the
authorization is conducted in the
discrete domain without using any
relaxation methods this is different
from the existing deep learning based
approaches that solve an approximate
problem using relaxation
the third component is hyper parameter
selection it builds and maintains a
surrogate model to continuously select
the best set hyperparameters used in
prediction and optimization
we compared our approach to the existing
step-free art approaches including the
two-stage ones and the deep learning
ones
our approach auto performed all of them
we worked very closely with our azure
partners and deployed this algorithm in
production
while keeping the over provision rate
reasonable and stable the heat rate is
about 93
the em prevision time is reduced by
about 42 percent
the results show that our algorithm is
quite effective in production
lastly let me
share some of our learnings and future
research opportunities
the first learning is about data culture
over the years we have seen tremendous
mindsets shift towards the data-driven
culture in both academia and industry
which is truly great
but we are not there yet
in practice there are still many issues
around data quality including missing
data noisy data delayed data and the low
value data etc
this reality brings up interesting
research opportunities
around the instrumentation how to make
it effective and efficient for example
where to log and where to log in the
code
and how to evolve instrumentation
around data quality management how to
conduct data quality testing and how to
continuously monitor the quality of data
pipelines
the second learning is about proactive
system design
here is a high level diagram
illustrating this idea
the top part is a traditional system
which monitors the input signals as the
current status of the system makes
decision and passes it to the action
taking component for execution
this traditional design is reactive
meaning it takes action only based on
the current status of the system
and
or the workload
in the design of a proactive system a
machine learning based prediction
component is added to the traditional
system the prediction system takes the
input signals does the necessary
processing
and outputs the future status of the
system or the workload
for example what the capacity status of
cluster a looks like next week whether a
disk will fail in a few days or how many
vms of a particular type will be needed
in the next hour etc
the future status of the system and
workload makes it possible for the
decision component to take proactive
actions to avoid negative impact on the
system for example the service
on an unhealthy computing node can be
live migrated to a healthy one to reduce
vm downtime another example is vm
pre-provisioning we just talked about
proactive system design brings up
research opportunities one is how to
design the learning based prediction
components the disk failure prediction
project is an example
the second is how to design the new
decision components when taking future
status into consideration the vm
pre-provisioning project is an example
to summarize today i talked about cloud
intelligence and i used two example
projects to demonstrate our work in this
research direction i also shared future
research opportunities in data quality
and proactive system design
at microsoft research we look forward to
working with more and more researchers
and practitioners
from both academia and industry on cloud
intelligence and making real world
impact
thank you